bonjour à toutes et à tous merci pour
l'invitation
je tiens à remercier tout d'abord
l'association tedx université paris
dauphine
moi j'ai fait très peu de préparation et
vous allez voir pourquoi
en plus j'ai toujours un peu de mal pour
pourparlers je préfère espionner
renseigner faire des investigations que
de parler donc pour moi c'est un défi
d'être d'être devant vous aujourd'hui
à l'origine je devais parler d'une
question qui m'est très souvent posées
par les étudiants qu'est-ce que je peux
faire après mes études
donc j'avais écrit une petit récit une
présentation on me préparer pour le tedx
est gelée j'ai soumis cette présentation
à mon ami et quelques jours elle la
regarde elle a lu elle a plié la feuille
et les partis de la salle de la fin de
du salon donc j'ai compris qu'en fait
c'était pas bon du tout qu'il fallait
que je recommence tout et surtout que je
trouve un autre sujet donc je me suis
dit que je devais parler d'un sujet qui
me tenait vraiment vraiment à coeur
depuis des années depuis depuis mes
saisons depuis mon adolescence et
c'était comment donner un sens à sa vie
alors à l'époque quand j'avais 16 ans la
question était un peu différente
c'était comment donner un sens à sa vie
quand on a arrêté l'école parce que j'ai
arrêté l'école à 16 ans qu'en première
quand on n'a pas une thune et quand on
n'a pas confiance en soi donc comme je
cherchais des des réponses à cette
question qui était vraiment prégnante
pour moi j'ai décidé à l'époque a tout
simplement de contacter des personnes
qui me semblait intéressante des
philosophes des auteurs des chercheurs
est la première personne qui m'a répondu
c'est c'la mayor qui était une hauteur
aventurière de 94 ans à l'époque donc
c'est en 97 elle est décédée évidemment
depuis une aventurière une sportive de
très haut niveau
qu'avait fait des jo est une très très
grande voyageuse est donc cette personne
ella maillart ma une suissesse m'avait
envoyé une carte que j'ai dit
aujourd'hui alors normalement il
faudrait que j'aie de la petite machine
ah oui j'ai donc en fait cette carte
postale que ce qui est ici la réponse
qu'il m'avait donné qu'en fait il s'agit
d'une d'une photo qu'elle a prise
pendant ses voyages qui est en russie
parce qu'elle était aussi journaliste
elle a aussi voyagé avec fleming qui est
le frère de petter fleming qui a écrit
james bond qui est aussi journaliste
espion pour l'émail 6 et l'émail five
est donc cette carte postale qu'elle
mike reid c'était en réponse c'est si
simple l'absolu donc le sens à la vie
c'est le tout qui nous réveille le effet
dire je suis conscient à moi de me
former vers ce que j'aime
ella maillart donc pour moi c'est un un
cadeau incroyable que j'ai reçue à
l'époque et elle m'a donné envie de
voyager j'avais besoin de ce genre de
message pour pour me donner confiance
il y avait aussi à cette époque donc
durant mais quand j'avais 16 ans et je
vais chercher l'inspiration auprès d'eux
d'autres personnes notamment des
personnes dans des récits des romans ou
des mythes donc pas uniquement des
personnes vivantes et je pense notamment
aux misérables que j'ai lues relues et
relu à cette époque parce que pour moi
c'est là où j'ai vraiment compris que
des gens qui étaient faibles qui étaient
pauvres pouvaient changer la vie et que
l'intérêt commun le bien commun
l'intérêt général avait vraiment un sens
même quand on était on n'avait aucune
chance et quand on était faible
donc pour moi ça m'a marqué durablement
sachant que déjà ce livre mon père me
l'avait lui quand j'étais enfant est
aussi toujours pendant cette période
j'ai énormément lu j'ai correspondu
aussi avec 1
un professeur qui est qui est mort qui
s'appelait un chercheur cabine cher en
énergie atomique quitté pierre samuel
qui était spécialisée aussi à côté dans
les mythes cd amazon et j'ai beaucoup
discuté avec lui changer avec lui
beaucoup de lettres parce que j'avais
compris entre intuitivement qui avait
une sagesse derrière les mythes qui est
qui et qui est plus fin qui est pas
vraiment enseigner ou 20 et ce qui
m'intéressait par exemple dans un mythe
comme l'iliade et l'odyssée en
particulier ulysse c'est que vous avez
un cours magistral de caisse que la ruse
et la ruse en fait c'est la force des
faibles et moi comme je me suis toujours
sentie voilà comme comme un faible je le
dis tranquillement je me pour moi
c'était la meilleure la meilleure des
écoles de comprendre
ulysse quand vous vous regardez dans
l'iliade et l'odyssée vous apprenez donc
la russe vous apprenez aussi ce qu'est
ce que le queiroz donc le queiroz quel
est le meilleur moment quand est ce qu
est le meilleur moment pour agir vous
apprenez aussi comment mourir
comment dire mourir symboliquement c'est
ce qu'apprend ulysse si on regarde bien
quand avec ses compagnons il crée par
ruse le cheval de troie ils
disparaissent c'est comme si c'était un
tombeau dans dans le cheval de troie
pour rentrer dans 3 et ensuite conquérir
la ville
ensuite quand ils sont face à pauli
femmes le cyclope ulysse devient
personnes il meurt il devient personne
et par cette ruse ensuite ils tuent
polyphème et ensuite à nouveau quand il
revient sur ithaque pour reconquérir sa
femme et son royaume dans son palais il
se fait passer pour un mendiant donc à
nouveau il meurt symboliquement il meurt
à la vue des autres et c'est cette force
cette sagesse grecque moelle qui m'a
toujours aussi inspiré plus tard dans
l'espionnage notamment quand j'étais à
jersey au luxembourg c'est à dire de
jouer sur la croyance des gens qui
pensent qu'ils peuvent vous écrasez donc
en fait toujours par être pour le plus
faible possible
donc ce que ce soit des personnes comme
ella maillart ou des chercheurs ou des
intellectuels ou que ça soit des récits
comme les misérables où les mythes pour
moi c'était vraiment fondateur j'avais
vraiment besoin à l'époque comme j'étais
en dehors du système scolaire de trouver
des repères de d'avoir des éléments qui
me rassure sur sur l'intuition sur l'
enthousiasme
sur la créativité sur la liberté parce
que je trouvais que la société dans
laquelle je vivais il y avait et 20
manque de tout c'est de toutes ces
valeurs moi qui que je sentais en moins
vibrer en moins donc serré si mon permis
justement et ces échanges m'ont permis
de gagner en force
encourageant confiance puis exactement
et ensuite de partir de partir de
c'était un peu l'appel du large donc
c'est un peu le deuxième cycle de ma vie
qui a commencé à 21 ans parce qu'après
donc j'ai passé le bac en candidat libre
et j'ai commencé des études à 21 ans un
nouveau geste et questionnement comment
donner un sens à ma vie parce que
j'arrivais toujours pas malgré toutes
ces rencontres ça restait toujours une
question qui n'était pas répondu
et donc j'ai décidé de pas de partir
alors que j'allais dire à l'étranger
mais non je suis parti en polynésie
française donc à l'autre bout de la
planète et j'ai découvert alors j'ai
découvert complètement un autre peuple
alors on pense toujours la polynésie
tahiti les vahinés etc
ça c'est une chose est en fait en
réalité vous avez un peuple vous avez
une culture la culture maori kaki et une
compréhension de la nature qui est au
delà de ce qu'on peut imaginer
donc en fait moi je suis partie à
l'origine parce que la petite amie de
l'époque que j'avais son père l'était
métropolitain avait une ferme père avait
des parts dans une ferme perlière sur un
apple et il m'a dit si tu veux on va te
former à être greffeurs de perles et on
invite à nous rejoindre pour moi c'était
vraiment comment dire le synonyme de
plein d' aventure des évocations à la
jack london donc moi je suis parti et
très rapidement et c'est un petit peu
quelque part quelque chose de récurrent
chez moi il faut crois que c'est
justement c'est un de mes sens à ma vie
je me suis rendu compte que le père de
mon ami en fait escroquer
détourné de l'argent de la ferme
perlière de son associé qui était maori
et il le prenait pour un idiot et donc
un jour
moi je suis allé voir l'associé maruis
jeux ludiques août
voilà je t'explique les comptes fascht
explique-t-on je te montre plus
exactement les fraudes et j'ai permis ou
maori de récupérer la totalité de sa
ferme
voilà donc c'était déjà à l'époque donc
en 2000 2001 je commençais déjà je
dirais à emmerder un peu le un peu le
monde
donc évidemment j'ai perdu enfin j'ai
perdu la relation avec mon mamont ami de
l'époque s'est arrêtée puisque
évidemment le pour le père j'étais
devenu persona non grata ensuite
beaucoup plus tard leur faut savoir
aussi que j'ai gardé beaucoup d'amis
donc s'il ya très longtemps mais j'ai
gardé beaucoup d'amis de la polynésie en
particulier du monde indépendantiste
parce que je comprends ce mouvement jeu
j'y adhère pour en partie donc après je
suis rentré en france et enfin métropole
et et j'avais toujours ce questionnement
qui était de plus en plus vibrants
comment donner un sens à ma vie
donc j'ai fait juste une petite
formation en hôtellerie de luxe pour
servir dans les hôtels de luxe et je
suis parti assez rapidement ensuite en
angleterre et en angleterre
j'ai rencontré une femme qui m'a dit un
jour qui est avocate
est-ce que ça t'intéresserait de
travailler à jersey c'est un paradis
fiscal en moi je savais absolument pas
ce qu'était un paradis fiscal
c'était très très vagues surtout à
l'époque les paradis fiscaux il y avait
très peu de choses de documentaires
d'information livre à ce sujet en 2007
avant l'homme devant la crise des
subprimes et moi j'ai dit tout de suite
oui sachant que évidemment je n'avais
aucune expérience dans la finance ou en
économie et intuitivement j'ai senti que
le monde de la ventura des s'ouvrir moi
je ne savais pas ce qui allait se passer
mais j'ai fait confiance à mon intuition
donc j'ai trouvé un travail
grâce au réseau de cet ami
entre autres dans le plus gros cabinet
d'avocats de l'île inquiets à l'époque
il s'appelait mourant et maintenant qui
est mourant du feu et jeunes aiment ou
parlant mourant et aux ânes et donc les
gens là c'était le bon côté du monde à
l'anglo saxonne ces délits vous forme
donc il vous forme sur les dossiers donc
très vite j'ai rentré dans un monde que
je ne connaissais absolument pas mais
j'ai tout comme j'étais passionné pour
comprendre ce qui se passait j'ai déjà
pris très rapidement et j'ai vu que
j'étais dans le saint des saints de la
finance donc après quelques mois j'ai
décidé de réaliser un rêve que j'avais
c'était de travailler avec la dgse
c'était quelque chose que justement que
j'avais visualiser des années auparavant
avec mon frère quand je faisais ma
formation pour travailler dans l'hôtel
et de pardon dans l'hôtellerie de luxe
où j'étais allé devant comment les
locaux de la dgse boulevard mortier
j'avais dit à mon frère tu m'avais pris
en photo un jour je travaillerai avec
eux et donc j'ai senti que j'avais cette
opportunité la vue tous les dossiers que
je voyais passer devant moi en
permanence de les contacter et donc donc
ça a commencé en 2007 et donc sans
rentrer étrangers d'être dans les
détails puisque toute façon j'en parle
dans mon livre là où l'argent
j'ai travaillé avec eux pendant pendant
cinq ans donc déjà à jersey ensuite
quand j'ai été muté au luxembourg j'ai
continué de travailler avec eux quand
j'étais au luxembourg alors en fait si
on regarde bien
pendant cette période
pendant sept
c'est le sens de ma vie qui m'a amené à
avoir à acquérir des savoirs faire si on
regarde bien c'est à dire j'avais aucun
savoir faire nous enfin je le répète
mais en économie en gestion en comptant
en droit puisque j'ai été confronté
énormément en droit des affaires anglais
anglo saxons et puis et puis j'ai appris
aussi le monde du skate etc le monde du
renseignement de l'intelligence
économique donc tout ça en fait tous ses
savoir faire sont venus uniquement sur
le pas ce que je cherchais en fait un
sens à ma vie et le le sens à ma vie
pour moi cette époque c'était une
mission c'était servir les intérêts de
la france jusqu'à ce que je me rende
compte
c'est un cycle qui a duré quand même
cinq ans que eelv un aspect de
désillusions de me rendre compte qu'il y
avait des dysfonctionnements assez grave
en tout cas à la dg se met surtout au
niveau des politiques et cette forme de
désillusion et déception était très
importante et créatives pour moi puisque
elle m'a fait je me suis senti obligé de
quitter tout simplement la finance et le
renseignement pour revenir pour revenir
en france
donc c'est un peu la fin d'un deuxième
cycle donc là cette époque là j'ai 32
ans
c'est une période aussi où je me suis
rendu compte parce que c'était alors
c'est pas une période où j'ai énormément
lu mais c'est une période où j'ai eu
beaucoup d'introspection
j'ai fait beaucoup d'introspection et où
je me suis rendu compte que le sens à ma
vie n'était pas extérieur à moi à chaque
fois je courais après comme si texto à
un mois et tout d'un coup je réalisais
qu'il était vraiment en moi en fait
c'était dans ce que je faisais et bon ça
peut paraître tout bête mais je m'en
étais jamais rendu compte auparavant
donc j'ai décidé de revenir en france et
créé tout simplement tout simplement les
sujets les projets de kiki que j'avais à
coeur sans passer par une entité comme
l'état où laurent ou la dgse et en
comptant je vais pas dire que sur
moi-même et que le désir viennent de moi
voilà c'est à dire que je cherchais +17
et à 10g cela que le couper le patient
pas voir la lumière
voilà
je peux continuer voilà va très bien
c'est très bien ça fait partie du jeu ça
fait partie du show donc en fait j'ai
décidé de revenir en france pour
réaliser les projets que j'avais à coeur
sans passer par par des entités
extérieures comme l'état la dgse ou
autre chose et donc j ai acheté une
petite maison dans les vosges et parce
que j'avais besoin de me mettre au vert
et j'ai commencé à faire du jardin je
connaissais absolument pas le jardin et
j'ai été surpris d'avoir une facilité à
jardiner à faire du maraîchage à un
immense plaisir et un immense plaisir
aussi à ne rien faire ce qui n'est
jamais un n'est pas vraiment c'est un
plaisir qui n'est pas vraiment appris
dans notre société parce que dans nos
sociétés il faut toujours faire être
actif etc
c'était un moment très important
d'apprendre à ne rien faire de vivre
aussi en communauté c'était le début de
de la communauté pour moi puisque mon
père et mon frère mon rejoint donc on a
fait du jardin ensemble on a eu des
poules enfin on était presque en
autarcie
et puis j'ai voulu en parallèle mettre
mon expérience je dirais de
renseignements au service des salariés
donc j'ai commencé à contacter des
syndicats des groupes de salariés qui
subissent aides et des liquidations
frauduleuses ou des détournements de
biens sociaux de la part d'actionnaires
ou de chefs d'entreprise et j'ai
commencé à faire des comment dire des
investigations pour ces groupes de
salariés ou syndicats et ses
investigations étaient ensuite utilisés
dans les rapports des avocats qui
attaquaient soit au tj donc au civil ou
au pénal pour demander des dommages et
intérêts donc j'ai fait ça pendant
pendant des années jusqu'en 2016 donc il
ya aussi une communauté qui s'est
développée de avec des amis lanceur
d'alert économistes syndicalistes
journalistes
voilà j'ai développé ça tranquillement
tout en faisant mon jardin et puis en
jouant en 2016 je sais pas c'est une
sorte d' idée qui m'est tombé dessus
donc là c'était en tout cas pour résumer
c'était le sens de ma vie était
et tu es plus clair pour moi tout d'un
coup je me suis dit il faut que j'écrive
ce qui s'est passé durant les cinq ans
de travail que j'ai fait pour la dgse
est ce que je fais jusqu'à maintenant
jusqu'en 2016 pour les salariés donc
j'ai cherché une maison d'édition j'ai
postulé pour une maison d'édition
j'ai envoyé un synopsis de deux pages
gtc les arènes qui ont pris mon faste et
par manuscrit s'étaient juste un
synopsis et ensuite je suis parti pour
deux ans d'écriture donc là c'est pareil
un nouveau il ya plusieurs enfants en
fait savoir faire qu'ils sont arrivés
sur sept ce cycle cette période
1 les investigations parce que même si
je faisais du renseignement avant que je
tapais des rapports pour la dg se faire
une investigation c'est pour des
salariés et des avocats c'est assez
différent
écrire un livre
bah c'est encore une autre un autre
savoir faire et donc voilà j'ai pris
deux ans ça a pris deux ans parce que
j'ai eu énormément de retour avec mon
éditrice pour parce qu'ils avaient peur
à juste titre qui est des procès et on a
eu zéro procès depuis la sortie du livre
qui est sorti à deux ans et se livre en
fête a été quelque chose d'incroyable
pour moi puisque c'était une porte
c'était une façon de faire plein de
rencontres à nouveau avec encore plus de
lanceurs dallaire plus d'économistes de
syndicalistes de gens de tout horizon
des ouvriers des ingénieurs des
polytechniciens donc s'agrandit cette
communauté d'amis dans laquelle on
partage en fait du renseignement pour
mieux comprendre tout ce qui est fraude
évasion fiscale
toutes ces choses là qu'on développe une
culture du renseignement
en dehors de l'état d'une certaine façon
et
voilà et/ou et à la sortie de ce livre
en fête aussi j'ai commencé à devenir
journaliste paris encore un autre
savoir-faire auquel je m'attendais pas
donc j'ai sorti une quinzaine
d'investigation notamment principalement
pour pour pour le média tv pour disclose
aussi et puis l'âge avait cofondé un
média avec denis robert que j'ai quitté
dernièrement pour des raison de
désaccords mais je lance en fait ma web
télé avec mon frère et des amis et des
partenaires très prochainement qui
s'appellera lanceurs d'alerté le but
c'est de montrer des dysfonctionnements
temps politique économique écologique et
mais aussi trouver des solutions avec
des boîtes à outils avec de la formation
ce que j'ai oublié de vous dire aussi
c'est que alors je sais pas s'il a
encore le temps en fait parce que je
parle je permets et c'est que j'avais
j'avais envoyé mon livre à john le carré
pour ceux qui connaissent un peu le dieu
de l'espionnage écrivains du monde de
l'espionnage est en fait le jour je
donnais à la sortie du livre où je
donnais une conférence à paris pour la
sortie du livre je reçois une lettre je
me suis dit ah ça y est c'est le premier
procès ça vient d'angleterre je vais y
avoir droit à la peine le livre est
sorti en fait c'était là bas la lettre
écrite à la main de john le carré
puisque john le carré il parle plusieurs
langues
enfin puisqu'il est décédé mais il
parlait allemand et français très
couramment qui me remercie vraiment
qu'ils me donnent des conseils
et là j'ai vu un être d'exception
c'est à dire qui était d'une générosité
incroyable
et comment dire d'une conscience
incroyable et cette conscience forcément
fin pour moi rejaillissait dans ses
écrits la conscience de donner
d'importants fin de l'importance de voir
l'autre et donc g us
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire c'est
que depuis le début de mes saisons j'ai
toujours eu des maîtres à penser j'ai eu
cette chance de pouvoir interagir avec
eux et ensuite il m'a envoyé une petite
carte qui était très sympa et il est
mort là il ya trois mois
voilà donc pour finir
donc là je vous parlais du troisième
cycle quel cycle jusqu'à maintenant
aussi à une communauté que j'ai co créé
qui entre aussi en parallèle à au projet
de la webtélé lanceur d alerte qui est
qui est réalisé avec des polytechniciens
avec des intersyndicales des politiques
et des économistes et qui a un groupe
sur sur comment dire concernant la
souveraineté économique
donc on va sortir le pit c2c de montrer
les dysfonctionnements de comment et
pourquoi on se fait voler notre
patrimoine économique et comment trouver
des solutions derrière donc on travaille
je suis très très content et devoirs je
suis ravi de voir la vitesse que ça
prend et la densité que ça prend donc
voilà ça c'est un peu le pour conclure
je dirai ce cycle c'est c'est l'époque
des communautés du partage et
des projets qui me tiennent à coeur et
enfin pour conclure cet entretien où
cette conférence tedx jeu direct pour
moi comment donner un sens à ma vie tout
simplement
quand je regarde ces trois cycles il ya
eu la première où j'ai besoin de
m'inspirer de personnes meetic ou
romanesques ou réelle pour partir
ensuite une fois que j'ai mise en
pratique comment dire que j'ai
expérimenté moi même le sens de ma vie
je me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait eu
des désillusions
donc je me suis recentré vers des
quelque chose de beaucoup plus
tranquille la nouveauté j'ai lu pas mal
de livres je pense à marc aurèle à à des
gens comme krishnamurti ou voilà où des
gens comme écartelé qui en fait le
voyage cette fois ci les plus intérieure
d'une certaine façon
et puis qu'est ce que je peux dire
d'autre penser oui conclure et avec avec
ella maillart en fait à nouveau
je pense que elle m'a vraiment fait tout
est dit dans cette carte dans cette
toute petite carte
le plus important c'est de de se rendre
compte qu'on fait partie d'un tout qu'on
n'est pas seul
il faut en être conscient il faut se
former à ça parce que l'on aime
donc je tenais à dire aujourd'hui merci
à la maillard merci à john le carré et
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]